once home to the world's loudest
political voice
the white house has been kind of well
orwellian quiet
a sound barrier by the deafening cries
of fraud
from a man clinging to his keyboard
today though this almost barren briefing
room
got back the man who lost and claims
he won big farmer ran millions of
dollars of negative advertisements
against me during the
campaign which i won by the way but you
know we'll find that out
almost 74 million votes
[Applause]
he hasn't taken questions since election
day
will you honor the will of the michigan
motor it's an end game
packed with outrage this republican
leader from michigan
heckled after being summoned to
washington
critics fear he could become a pawn in a
presidential push
to undermine results
enter the elite strike force team
a parade of the president's defenders in
what felt
like a coronavirus capsule they claim
american democracy is broken
30 lawsuits have been filed but so far
no court has found evidence of
widespread fraud
but be patient they said as we watch
the slow drip of a black liquid from
rudy giuliani's temples
you're painting a portrait of a national
conspiracy suggesting that
joe biden was actually part of that do
you
provide any evidence it began as a
national
conspiracy clearly that evidence emerged
very very quickly
it is exactly what his aggrieved
employer
wanted to hear giuliani how's the
president feeling
president feels great why do you think
the president's so quiet at the moment
so i appreciate it thank you guys it's
very rare to hear the president
so quiet isn't it no
i thought mayor giuliani did a great job
of representing the case
some republicans seem privately
embarrassed but
few appear willing to go public trying
to
ride out the storm assuming it won't
destroy them
or public faith
joe biden is trying to build a
government with a tenant who doesn't
want to hand over the keys
but in georgia his right to them
certified
after a hand recount close elections so
distrust
people feel their side was cheated we
saw this from the democrats in 2018
and we see this from republicans today
working as an engineer throughout my
life i live by the motto
that numbers don't lie that's faith in
facts what a democracy depends on
but there's another big step in this
saga december the 14th
when electors in every state meet and
cast their ballots
it should deliver certainty but doubt
and discord
may already have taken root cordelia
lynch sky news washington